the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so let's let's turn the page to
storyboarding which for us you know you
know no matter what sort of video you're
doing live-action animation or some sort
of combination is is vital to the
process because and here's why it allows
you basically a you know a lot of
freedom to not have to make any really
high-stakes creative decisions and just
sort of be creative at a very early
stage you don't have to commit to any
sort of production at that point
that's why we've that's why we do it and
it's why we share it with clients before
we commit to doing any animation because
it's very time consuming for us to
animate and we want the client to know
what we're doing before we commit to
doing any of that really labor-intensive
work it serves as a blueprint for timing
and visual flow so you can get a sense
of the pacing of the video whether or
not you know as Elizabeth was saying
things are going to get stale at a
certain point it can help you make those
sorts of creative decisions without
having to commit a lot of resources the
storyboard can reveal you know where
you're going to need to shoot what props
you're going to need the types of shots
you're going to you're going to employ
all that decision making gets made and
the storyboarding process and another
really crucial thing is so often when
we're doing a storyboard room we realize
that the script needs to be different
you write something maybe you have some
visual sense when you're writing a
script and that's good because you've
you know and I've done it a lot so a lot
of times I am thinking visually but I'm
not always thinking visually and I'm I'm
not it's not my strong suit all the time
when I'm script writing so a lot of
times will be in a story board meeting
will say well you know this line is sort
of dumb you know why don't we say this
so that we can show this you know so
that integration of visual and aural you
know the voice is is a really crucial
part of the story of storyboarding you
know so that's why we storyboard and let
me just show you an example of one of
our storyboard so I'll there are many
different ways to storyboard but I'll
just show you one example the first is
well I'll show you this storyboard for
this video we did for NASA actually and
it was produced by Dobby na T in in New
York and they asked us to create a
series of videos about different physics
topics and this one is on centripetal
force
so I'll just switch over to let's see
episode so this is essentially this is
our this is our storyboard method we we
do an Excel spreadsheet with three
columns shot narrator and notes very
simple I can
I'm email me and I'll send you this too
I'll send you this storyboard you can
use it in your own work if you want
imagine you've got a tennis ball so we
start the shot on the tennis ball
we either pull back I think it will
watch the video I can't remember the
camera pulls back or we jump cut or
something attached to a piece of string
and we pull back further and you start
swinging it and then when did we have
this idea for the dog I mean I probably
this came in in the storyboard meeting
like okay well that will have this nice
dog element to the to the experience in
circles and so gradually the cameras
getting further back and now we can see
the background
whoa now watch out for your buddy it you
know this is not for adults by the way
I'm sorry I should have mentioned that
this is for like elementary and middle
schoolers so if you find this little
facile and dumb
just imagine you're 13 years old watch
out for your buddy
so the the guy on the the skateboard
ducks down and then he goes past and in
waves
let's take so so we start with you know
my attitude about this in a lot of cases
is to start with action like start with
something that's really compelling like
some you know you don't have to start
right away explaining things just sort
of start with with imagining something
or doing something there's that old
comment I think I think this is
Hemingway said this in many talked about
in media stressed start in the middle of
things so don't start with elaborate
sort of explanations just start like in
the middle of the action so something
needs to be happening at the video at
the beginning of a video so that's why
we chose to start you know get this ball
spinning you know there's something
going on there's this dog there's
there's the kids skateboarding by your
you're starting with a high level of
engagement and interest you know let's
take a closer look at the fascinating
physics of this simple action okay and
then we go into the the deep more
detailed analysis of what's really going
on we talk about F equals MA Newton's
second law and how it relates to objects
moving so I'm not going to show you the
whole story board but you start to get a
sense of how we put this thing together
visually in a very methodical way before
we did any work they I mean this is work
but before we did any you know animation
or illustration and I think John did all
the artwork for this and and it's very
basic she's basically a stick figure
but John makes really nice stick figures
so he has that talent so let me just
show you the video and it came out of
that process
hold on a second here we go
whoops that's not the right one there we
go this is a minute and 46 so our
challenge was to do these topics in
about a minute and a half minute 45
seconds imagine you've got a tennis ball
attached to a piece of string and you
start swinging it-- in circles whoa now
watch out for your buddy let's take a
closer look at the fascinating physics
of this simple action you've probably
heard of Newton's second law of motion
as it relates to objects moving in a
straight line
turns out Newton's second law also tells
us about the net force on an object as
it moves in a circle when an object
moves in a circle its velocity changes
direction since the velocity is changing
that means we have an acceleration and
we know from Newton's second law that if
we have an acceleration we have a net
force now back to our spinning ball for
objects undergoing circular motion the
net force on the object is called the
centripetal force
it's a weird-sounding word but it's
latin for the phrase center seeking its
name centripetal because the centripetal
force always points to the center of the
circle the ball has a tangential
velocity so if you suddenly cut the
string it would fly off in whatever the
tangential direction was at the moment
you made the cut but assuming you don't
cut the string and you keep swinging the
ball the balls tangential velocity is
constantly changing directions this
means the ball is accelerating and the
reason it's accelerating is due to the
centripetal force the centripetal force
acting on the ball is constantly
directing the ball towards the center of
the circle your hand this combined with
the balls velocity keeps the ball
swinging in a circle the same
centripetal force that keeps the tennis
ball swinging in a circle also keeps
rollercoasters on the track as they go
through a loop-de-loop so the next time
you're having a blast on a roller
coaster
you can thank this in Tripp little force
okay so yeah so that's a pretty short
little ditty but you can I just wanted
to show you how we built it
and this next thing is I'm not going to
show the whole thing but I it's it's
interesting this is a video as sort of
an insight or a look at how Pixar does
their storyboarding and I'll just play a
little bit of it and then perhaps you
can watch the whole thing on your own
time
alright so this section is the
storyboarding process and this is where
instead of writing with words we write
with drawings and we put them on little
pieces of paper and it's sort of seeing
the movie in comic book form and we'll
do a section of a movie at a time and
we'll pin them all up on boards and then
when we get a certain chunk done we'll
show them to the directors or they will
show them to us and I don't know it's
kind of complicated you know that was a
really good description about how better
to do described better than that yeah
well we could show it yeah let's show it
with storyboards with storyboards okay
this is the storyboarding process yes
illustrated by Joe Ranft tower head of
story yes so there's the little cute mr.
storyboard artist working very
diligently and happily in January and he
has a deadline he's working hard to do
his sequence every time he does a
drawing he pins it up on the board and
there he stands back when he gets done
with the sequence and he says mm-hmm did
I do it the best way and storyboarding
actually balances like composition
cutting staging acting writing
everything that goes through the
storyboard artists mind as he's doing it
so he'll try another pass at it a couple
more times until he feels he's got it
just right just right it's perfect so he
calls in the story Department and of
course the director you can see jon
laaser thanks Joe and then Joe or
whoever's pitching well the little
storyboard artist in this case will
pitch the sequence and in the middle of
a pitch Jon gets an idea we all get
ideas and that's one of the great things
about storyboarding here at Pixar is it
it is a free-for-all once we get in this
and everybody is out coming up with
ideas to make the sequence better to
make the film better and when the pitch
the session is done inevitably there is
lots of ideas to make the sequence
better the storyboard are kind of wakes
up from it right we're infamous for
putting all our notes on little post-its
yeah that's why you see a little yellow
squares there and so we'll leave all
excited about the great new ideas we've
got boom and land the storyboard artist
mr. storyboard artists goes back and
thinks about it and starts over with all
of his notes that he has to do
Joe ramped often calls it the
storyboarding process not storyboarding
but story reborn because we work on it
redo it redo it redo it to make each
sequence to make the entire film as best
as we possibly can be in the next
section you're going to see Joe ramped
our head of story on a bugs life
pitching to Co director Andrew Stanton
me and and I think Bob's I think he's
pitching the circus sequence from a
bug's life enjoy
okay so slim and Frances are hit by the
spotlight they're not too excited and
swims let's try la la la la spring is in
the air and I'm a flower with nothing
interesting to say and then they go ah
look I'll be behind Lee comes running
forward I will be here I come you just
can't catch up and suck it's just you so
heavy it's just hard for him to like
catch up to ya so he's like your flower
slow down slow down ok ok so then he's
chasing after him and I am like runs by
the stands and is just a little kid even
candy corn and he stops he goes turns or
he goes Oh candy corn here oh you have
to let me eat it help you let me help
you to finish it
oh we're thinking of red box
sombrero jujube
those are kind of funny the question is
what would a fly like as far as candy
goes
well dots but we already have a
character candy cards pretty funny
though cuz it's really like it's a big
big triangle I think that okay yeah
that's why I think we should go with
candy cards like is it too Halloween no
okay so he goes OH
candy corn here let me help you finish
today obviously they went with a candy
corn anyway go ahead guys oh sure yeah
yeah
okay no problem no problem here
because I've been seeing all these very
gorgeous storyboards like even you guys
talk about how like not when the real
work starts but obviously that takes a
lot of time and talent so this was a
storyboard that Ashley did for our very
first episode of science at loud just to
show you how basic it can be and still
be effective so she did an episode on
exoplanets
Ashley's came to a video whoo-ahh and
what we discovered after she stored word
in this she's talking about a very
abstract cosmic topic so obviously we
can't go into space which made deciding
what the visuals were going to be
surprisingly difficult or maybe should
have been unsurprising but we were noobs
at the time so it was hard but she's
literally just drawing stick figures
aligning them with her text and when we
were looking at the storyboard we were
like wow there's not really a whole lot
going on except for her just standing
there and basically half of the video
was going to be an animation without her
on screen and there would have been no
way for us to really anticipate the
extent to which she was missing from
screen and Toshi storyboarded this out
for us and so she tweaked not only her
visuals but she ended up tweaking her
script a lot after she did this to sort
of make room for scenes in which she
could be more present where it could be
more than a fully animated video but in
case you wanted to see we actually kept
the first six sort of frames pretty
similar to her original plan and we just
tried to alter the animations to make it
a little more engaging so I'll show you
the first part of her video
this rock in Hazzard
so this is um this animation was
actually done by our first editor
twenty-five years ago most people would
have told you that there are only nine
planets in the universe since then we've
lost them sorry Pluto both discovered
thousands of others so what happened did
astronomers suddenly got a new pair of
glasses and now we're meeting all of our
new neighbors
well no it turns out we could have seen
these exoplanets all along but we only
recently figured out exactly where and
how to look we call these new planets
exoplanets or so because we knew what
she wanted to do with the animations
ahead of time because of her storyboard
that allowed us to direct her while we
were shooting to put her hands down to
look up at the ceiling and do all that
stuff and I'll show you one more
storyboard that was done a little bit
differently oh man all that Josh talk
again but Alex actually just did
pictures for some of them so he did an
episode on how carbon nanotubes are made
and he had this sort of imagine a blank
opening and so he just took pictures of
the locations and types of places that
he wanted to go and then from there he
literally just drew stick figures so you
don't have to draw anything crazy
beautiful no offense to Alex but this
was actually very helpful for us as well
to sort of see how the pacing of his
demos were going to go so we altered his
script again after he made this because
we sort of realized that it was a lot of
just him sitting at a table demoing
things and we decided that there needed
to be something a little more visually
engaging besides him just at a table but
he's talking about how thread made out
of carbon nanotubes could lift up
something as heavy as an elephant we
quickly realized that we wouldn't have
footage for that but this is sort of
again really basic nothing too crazy but
helped us a lot in the planning of the
video so I'll show you the first couple
bits of his
imaginary material that would let you
use your phone for weeks without a
charge what we're letting you build an
elevator these elevators and batteries
can one day exist with a material called
carbon nanotubes carbon nanotubes are
tiny take this human hair for example
you need 10,000 carbon nanotubes to make
a rope as big as this hair
despite being small they're really
strong this cotton string holds out this
Lego car fine but if it was made from
carbon nanotubes it can hold up a real
car so originally he was going to talk
about this model of carbon nanotubes at
the very beginning of the video but
after we saw the storyboard we thought
that we should wait until later on to
explain it and just hit them with this
example first so I just wanted to show
you guys that so you knew that your
storyboards don't have to be anything
super complicated
all right so some just some we're almost
done with this by the way but some some
quick tips first storyboarding and I
guess this was something that Elizabeth
was just saying it doesn't have to be a
work of art stick stick figures work
focus on details that matter we we don't
draw a lot of backgrounds or we just
draw the the bare minimum of elements
that will get across the the intention
of the scene or the shot rather should
include a composition in camera angles
you know is this wide shot is it a
close-up
what is the camp you might make a note
about what the cameras doing is it
pulling back is it on a dolly is it
tracking something and just so you guys
know em since we haven't really talked
about that stuff yet yeah that's a lot
of stuff that Chris is going to talk
about tomorrow so I would suggest that
you try to keep that stuff in mind and
then maybe revisit it again after Chris
talks about tomorrow - yeah you can also
ask him while he's here - yeah and Chris
I mean Chris knows the grammar of this
stuff better than I do I you know I
admit I didn't go to film school so we
we use terms of art you know in our
studio that probably are appropriate but
you know the cameras close-up on this
guy the cameras far back from this guy
you know the cameras moving while this
guy is talking you know that's sort you
know any of that stuff don't don't be
constrained by you know right
- using in the shop the tree yeah it was
I live in turn sideways like yeah
where's there another shortcut this yeah
well a note card is very turned sideways
is perfect you know is a good sixteen by
nine approximation the the the template
that I'm gonna give you guys is is you
know widescreen but yeah definitely have
to think about those sorts of things you
know you don't want to be doing it in a
four by three box you know you want to
think about the full frame and this is
you know this is sort of stupid I don't
know why I put this make them easy to
read visually and understand you know so
you know I think one thing I wanted to
really stress is that for us and I think
for most people as you saw in the Pixar
video storyboarding is a collaborative
process so you know you can't this is a
process this is this kind of art is
something that comes out of a lot of
different minds working together
creatively and so the story one reason
to make the storyboard really easy to
understand is that be somebody else is
gonna have to use it and work on it it's
not just what's inside your head your
this is a part of a process that
collaborators are all working on so it
has to communicate very effectively and
I haven't mentioned this formally yet
but obviously if you're going to be
hosting your video you can't
simultaneously be shooting it as well so
the way that's going to work is will
partner you guys up or we'll figure
something out to our basically you'll be
shooting someone else's video and
someone else
be shooting yours and the storyboard is
going to be really important for that
reason because you have to somehow give
the instructions to whoever's shooting
for you exactly how you want things
framed what you want your shot to look
like and things like that so agree
completely it's a very collaborative and
necessary thing yeah you know if there's
time make make a few boards like a lot
of times people in our office will make
some boards independently of each other
and then we'll bring them all together
and see what we've all got sometimes
that's part of our workflow
if you have time storyboard the same
script and in a couple of different ways
you might get different ideas with
different perspectives and as I said
before revise the script as needed
sometimes a great visual idea doesn't
line up with the script focus on visual
story not adherence to your script
so if you come up with a cool idea and
you may expect you know this is hard to
see I can say this but you just have to
experience it to really understand it
you might come up with a cool idea but
the script doesn't quite match what
you're saying so don't feel like you're
locked into that script and finally the
storyboard is only a guide changes are
often made in the production and editing
process so all this stuff is very
plastic you know you're you're moving it
you're changing it as you go all right
so how to make a storyboard we brought
some paper templates you can use note
cards which a note cut we don't use note
cards but it's actually an interesting
idea which is that then if you put one
seam or one shot on each card you can
start moving the cards around on the
wall which might be interesting an
interesting way to do it and each frame
should include the script line and basic
direction notes we don't always do that
but we at minimum we include the script
line that's coordinated with that's with
with the shot
so let's workshop and there's a couple
different ways we can do this
well first let me go over what I think
we're what I this basic format will John
and I will sit up here and storyboard a
script and what that script is I want to
talk to you about in a minute and then
once we've done some of it maybe over 30
45 minutes will give we'll break you
into small groups and you'll continue
the same the same script storyboarding
it you'll do if you do some frames on
your own we'll walk around and help you
and then you guys will present what you
have and we'll just we'll just share and
discuss them yeah that works that would
work great yeah sure yeah that would
work great keynote PowerPoint that would
that be great and you don't have to use
these paper sheets but unless you have a
Wacom with you it can be difficult to
draw on your computer so the script that
we're going to storyboard we can either
do a script that we've already done or
that we've already written in
storyboarded and produce but it would be
it would be wonderful to storyboard it
again with all of your input or we can
take one script that you guys are
currently working on and just get
started on it with you so either someone
is either someone is either a victim or
very lucky or some combination of the
two in this who votes for storyboarding
one of our scripts okay somebody okay
who votes okay
so fine so it sounds like you want a
storyboard one of your scripts
all right who wants the storyboard one
of their scripts oh come on guys
this is absurd oh you mean the hotel
works yeah do you have
should we just storyboard the the latest
script that you uploaded to the tumblr
and so he's got an idea that he hasn't
fully scripted yet oh okay yeah it might
be easier if we have actual like textual
yeah we need a script just for for
logistical purposes does anyone yeah
it's not gonna be your entire script
it's just gonna be a portion a couple
scenes from it does anything feel
comfortable and it's okay if you end up
changing it completely - yeah yeah and I
thought that - that was kind of what we
were planning to do but I didn't want it
I didn't want to make it all about us
but if you think it's instructive then
okay okay okay cool
so I do have a script here
do you want them to do pencil doesn't
matter it doesn't matter pencil is nice
because you can erase it yeah so I think
what we'll do is we'll start off we'll
start off with John working and we'll
all will chime in and then you can see
how John works and then you can do it
yourself
does that make sense yourselves I have
the script actually so you can see what
I was hoping we'd do this is a video at
another one of those wnat episodes on
mass and force I hope I printed out
enough of these I may not have okay some
people are gonna have to share
unfortunately okay so John we use flash
a lot just for for illustration and for
storyboarding and for some animation
components I won't go into all that but
what John has here is a Wacom tablet and
it allows us to just get our ideas in
the computer basically so I need the
script alright so let's just let's just
focus on the first paragraph okay and in
order for this work to work I please
chime in and participate in this process
because what I'll end up happening is
we'll end up with exactly the same thing
we already did and I don't want to do
that mass is a measure of an object's
ability to resist being accelerated by a
force that means the more massive an
object is the hard it is to make it move
if it's at rest or to stop it if it's
moving so so thinking about the need to
make the beginning of a video very
interesting and
immediately engage of you or how do we
want to start this one
okay mass is a measure of an object's so
we've got an object what kind of object
do we want huh
a fat man something big something iconic
something something that really
symbolizes mass a building a monument
how about what are you gonna say Josh
okay that could work okay a brass wait
yeah an anvil those are iconic things
yeah yeah that's that'd be loot that the
Looney Tunes approach for sure okay so
what do you think John should we go with
you know something big that falls is it
good do we need the word mass on the
screen okay something big that falls
why don't we do the let's go with it
let's go with let's try out this idea of
the word mass being made out of stone
that's kind of interesting it falls and
like crumbles pennant like creates this
sort of cloud of dust and stuff it
sounds good
such a question yeah how many no story
- what yeah that's a good question what
do you think about that John I think
that's up to you I mean I'm a very
visual person so for me I'd like to draw
maybe three or four frames of this mass
dropping down but for you maybe you
could just make one drawing and next to
the storyboard explain the action
explain what's going on yeah a lot of
times we draw red arrows to indicate
movement so you could draw the word mass
at the bottom of the screen with the
clouds and and have a red arrow facing
down
you definitely want to do another board
for that
and John is drawing in like a like just
a horizon here so you have a sense of
the scene just in a bear at a very basic
level and where you know this the back
where the background is going to be and
where the word is going to land and I
think that's enough for the first line
yeah and this is just the beginning to a
lot of times with our storyboards we'll
just draw out our ideas and then we'll
come to the end of the whole storyboard
and take a look at it and we'll say oh
we have this ending but it doesn't
really match at the beginning so then we
go back and maybe we change the
beginning to more match the end you know
we're just getting all our ideas out but
you're not locked into this idea now
that we've drawn it right okay so next
line that means the more massive an
object is the hearted it the harder it
is to make it move if it's at rest or to
stop it if it's moving and that yeah so
what do you think about that one we've
got this object that's fallen onto the
screen and now we're talking about
moving it and stopping it yeah yeah
I think that's a natural very very
iconic way of doing that so we have a
character now who comes in and you know
like this oh god you know I was trying
to push this thing
and either for the second portion
in the in the thing slums then the mess
will come sliding up to the guy he is to
try to stop if I can see it's like that
key to the wall
okay what if what if this little guy
tries to push it and then maybe an
elephant comes on the other side of the
word and pushes and if it is effective
at pushing it towards him and then he
has to like go like this to get it just
he's like oh my god and he can't stop it
and he gets pushed off the screen
something like that with that uh-huh
oh that's a good idea yeah so then it's
gravity is working on the the word then
that could that could work yeah yeah
yeah he tries to get out of the way
okay great so that covers the first
paragraph for me or you guys you think
we're this is a good start so let's
let's start with the next sentence
are you all set yep okay the nifty thing
about mass is that it doesn't
necessarily have to do with size think
of a big pile of rocks and a big pile of
feathers both piles are the same size or
volume but it would take a lot more
effort or force to move the pile of
rocks than it would to move the pile of
feathers the reason rocks have more mass
than feathers because they're more dense
all right so how do we tackle this one
okay
cool maybe it may that's nice well I
like the idea of coke making it cohesive
you know like it's all come it's all
working together so maybe the mass
slides down the ramp and and hit
something and breaks apart into a pile
of rocks or there's a pile of rocks on
one side of this screen what's that oh
that's a good idea
that's an interesting idea oh so this
characters a bird I like that idea
yeah so he's pushing against it and then
it starts then things tilt and it starts
to slide forward yeah but but it's
somebody suggesting that this guy's a
bird yes okay so how are we going to do
this in a kind of fun nonviolent way
that this this bird like you know yeah
well I mean they could just sort of
divinely appear like they could just
fall from the top of the screen
you know yeah yeah and let me back up
for a second because let's think about
this in terms of so this this first
scene obviously we're talking about
animation here like we're not going to
do this live action right but let's
let's imagine that the next scene this
the second paragraph is live action so
then we're talking about more of like an
idea like you have you know where you
have some actual people moving rocks
around and you have maybe somebody
dumping out feathers right do is out is
that what we want to do is kind of a
combo here I know I may be bringing it
maybe
of Weber comes in the mess were forced
into his head
see
okay so you're talking about a nice
transition between between that could be
interesting
yeah so then we have a yeah so then we
have a host at the throughout we start
with a host a talking head and then we
have the mass fall down beside him you
see how this gets complicated right
there's lots of different ways to do
things right well for the sake of
simplicity let's let's continue as if
this we're just gonna animate this video
okay is that okay with you Elizabeth
wait okay just just so that we you guys
get the sense of the process but you can
already see that there are so many
options right there's so many different
ways to do things okay so back to our
feathers the nifty thing about mass is
that it doesn't necessarily necessarily
have to do with size all right so we've
got this this mass that's rolled down
the hill and I like the idea of that
hitting something and turning into a
pile of rocks are we gonna go with that
idea okay yeah it goes off a cliff
a pillow factory that's funny yeah
that's funny all right so here we have
our cliff and this will cut you know
this action will cover the nifty thing
about mass
and then down in the valley for the
canyon is the Acme pillow company
bellows RS okay so so we've got to do
think of a big pile of rocks and a big
pile of feathers boom
then maybe we cut then we cut to a pilot
we cut to a pile of rocks and a pile of
feathers so this is kind of a jump cut
to a close-up
both piles are the same size or volume
but it would take a lot more effort or
force to move the pile of rocks than it
would new to move the pile of feathers
so maybe our protagonists are our little
guy who was holding the the the the the
mast thing needs to come back in here
what do you what should he do now yeah
we could do it that way
wind is hmm potentially yeah yeah or
maybe he well any other ideas
yeah that could work
yeah
by adding on to that maybe he tries to
blow the rocks and nothing happens then
he kicks it
yeah
so what do we have we have a leaf blower
we have cleaning up scenario you want to
try the leaf blower
sure or anything else is there any way
we can connect this with the beginning
in the beginning he's trying to move
this word mass is there anything there
is he maybe you know that janitor and
this this mass is making is in his way
he doesn't like it there and then he's
trying to do the same thing here he's
trying to clean up this mess I don't
know just spitballing here
is there a way we can tie the two things
together is the question
and I was thinking that he's running or
with because he's running away from
their singing
he runs a along with the maze and
crashes and boom it lands in dependency
it's like getting away from a favorite
this case of fetters then she tries to
clear the wrong that's an interesting so
it's what does it say here think of a
big pile of rocks and big pile of petal
feathers both piles are the same size or
volume but would take a lot more effort
or force to move the pile of rocks and
when to move the pile of pile of
feathers so I think we're back to a
scenario where we need to have some sort
of like we need to show force being
exerted you know so it would take a lot
more effort or force to move the big the
pile of rocks so what sort of how can we
show that
I mean we've almost already showed it in
a way yeah or maybe just our character
like trying to push this pile of rocks
again like he's it's like oh man not
again I got to push something else you
know what's that
yeah yeah right right
deck
he's on his way to school or something
and this adventure happens yeah yeah and
the audience's kids you know this is
middle schoolers yeah so we could add a
note you know to the first scene that
like kid with backpack
okay so so we we agree that so this kid
is going to try to move these rocks in
some way he's trying to push him or or
gets his back up against him and tries
to get him out of the way
the effectively isn't a right to cater
faders yeah or on someone sleeping at
one of them and the rocks will be this
like construction truck the TV thing
comes in it loose it up
yeah yeah does that does that really
just show the notion of differing
amounts of force being neaten required
that's a good question
yeah place
maybe we use the heavy machinery to move
the rocks and then we just move our
little character and he can move the
feathers yeah that could work yeah like
a big backhoe has to move the rocks but
the the character is able to just either
blow on the feathers or move them out of
the way really easily
okay yeah that's nice that work does
that sell it as we say so we need to
show that the do we need to show the
backhoe first it would take a lot more
effort or force to move the pile of
rocks and then we have another shot then
it would to move the pile of feathers
back COFA yeah
we see the rocks gone in the next scene
yeah
okay so it gets so the feathers are gone
and then we've got another line here
the reason rocks have more mass than
feathers because they're more dense
is yeah right right if I'm not a
scientist and you guys can help me with
this but this this density really equate
to weight like to do if we just show
them on a scale does that really showing
that one is more dense than the other
are you rats
could we do something like just very
simple where we just the character
extends two hands and when one hand is a
rock and then the other is a feather and
we just and we put we put the words more
dense above the hand with the rock in it
or something like that how do you how do
you how do you visually tell say
something's more dense like how do you
show that baby machine was because
trolled they're all soft into the ocean
you see the rough sinking and in the
messages
maybe just landing on a surface
finish your stencil SN I'm not sure how
familiar the kids were the concept of
density yeah
but having the water sinking floating
the point a bit better
okay well if you are you like you
already introduced all hand
so I'm do like to introduce density
would really be doing like what came
from to the bar not to do it do it just
it's like density is volume and mass so
if you're able to have volume and then
go to mass after that I think that's
where they connect that the mass can be
different even though the volume is the
same and you select different constants
yeah it may not even why maybe it's okay
to just say one's more dense than the
other right it's like a what couple
minute videos yeah yeah the point is
really about how things that have more
mass require more force mm-hmm if you
start going into the density I'm afraid
that people would also want to talk
about what the difference between weight
and mass are yeah true yeah so again
it's like at one point are you branching
off
from the main point of the video I don't
think I knew the story that's a good
point yeah
well the reason rocks have more mass
than feathers because they're more
different yes and maybe remember what we
did and then with the video we actually
ended up producing but I I think I would
go with with the hint with the hands for
displaying the two things you sort of
think about how they're essentially the
same size but one is very light and what
is one is one is this rock
you know it's dense can um is it
possible to sort of zoom in on the rock
intensity is really that there's like
more stuff per space right mm-hmm
so somehow like have the rock bulge a
little bit to show that that frame is
like stuffed with as much stuff as
possible
yeah then show the feathers and show
like a lot more air and space in between
the feathers mm and you can still put
the label more intense but maybe there'd
be some sort of visual
with that as well yeah potentially hmm
this is a toughy you say maybe we cut to
a new shot where we see a rock and a
feather side-by-side and then maybe we
see like a a view of each one under a
microscope I like that idea the the
microscope image like we show like the
crystalline structure of the the rock is
like really you know it's like a lot of
stuff packed in there
it's complicated so your tip to go with
this
like I don't know the word dance like
I don't think we have to I don't know if
we have to
yeah well let's let's think of another
strategy here how necessary do you think
this line is in the script I mean is it
is it vital to the script itself I mean
to the whole story I don't know I
haven't given you guys a chance to read
the whole thing but maybe this is one of
those moments where we take this line
out and we end this we end the the
paragraph with moving the feathers yeah
it is easier and it might and it might
be one of those moments where this line
is a distraction from the yeah yeah
so let's let's say okay we're going to
remove this line for now and and you
know some some client is going to come
to you and say why did you guys take
that line out you know we really need
that and then you have to argue for that
that's part of the that's all part of
the process right like well we you know
we talked about this for about an hour
and we realized that this wasn't really
important to the process you know and
that it happens all the time yeah yeah
in my professional opinion and that's
when I have to sort of fake this
professional persona we don't think you
should have this line in the script and
in retrospect what this line is in the
video we but we didn't have 15 people to
talk about it with we only had four
people okay with taking that
like you see why maybe that's a good
choice would you have reacted that's
positively to the idea of taking us out
maybe five days ago before we've gone
through this class because I feel like
that is the reaction of a lot of science
it's like wait wait you know this is
accurate but it's not precise like
George's talking about you know you have
to talk about density and that's sort of
but I mean I want to tie this back to
the work that you guys are doing out you
guys see how this process is like really
making you examine what is truly
necessary and what is it to the project
right cuz this is gonna happen to your
scripts - you're gonna sit down and
storyboard and you're gonna rack your
brain over one sentence that you can't
think of an appropriate efficient before
and maybe that's key for you to
reconsider whether or not that part is
truly vital but you would not force to
do that until you think about things
like storyboarding and think about
things like an overall narrative to your
video cause otherwise you're gonna do
what most scientists do at night I mean
I like say this as a former amateur look
but like the tendency is to just throw
as much information out there to cover
your guns yeah and I and I think if I
remember correctly this script was a lot
more complicated
we received a kind of rough script from
the client and I had to edit it down and
get it into something that that worked
you know in the for the medium and and
we had some discussions about well like
what why can't we say that I mean that
exactly what you're talking about
happened and I think that this one just
sort of slipped through you know this
one got through and in retrospect maybe
we shouldn't have produced that line but
I love that we're thinking about this
you know I think this is a really cool
this is a really important part of the
process for another one
you know your audience right the growing
about your audience and you know I was
actually earlier today company one of my
graduate fellows applied for the Masters
of journalism program here and she has
to write a 500-word piece of it and she
was trying her hardest to consolidate an
experiment right and she was trying to
think about what the lay audience cares
about and it was so hard for her and she
distilled it down the lane two and a
half sentences but I I told her even
that was too much bird library York
Times piece that don't cares about which
mice were chosen and why for this
experiment and that this video is the
crux of like what I think is the hardest
thing right when they're words I think
on Monday we heard that phrase kill your
darlings you know there's that you know
yeah yeah yeah exactly and and kind of
and I think in retrospect than
introducing the notion of density into
this is a real distraction you know it's
not what this is about so yeah so I
would say let's strike that line that we
have the luxury of doing that so I want
to stop there with our portion of it and
then kind of let you guys break up into
groups and do maybe the next two
paragraphs if you make it further that's
fine and then we'll walk around and kind
of talk to you about your ideas but so
how many of us are that there's one
there's seven eight okay so that is nice
two groups of four and yeah I'll let you
divide up however you want if you just
want to go with you for over here and
then you four over here is fine
you guys from this are you guys I would
say you know not not all three of you
guys together because you know each
other and all that but yeah that's let's
get started with that
that's a good idea
yeah yeah let's take a break before you
start thank you so what do you what do
you guys got is this thing on
sorry all right hot mic all right
so we put a separate pair ago yeah let's
see how to show how well pictures do it
in in integer so
teacher so the students like really
happy a little bit teacher fired because
he has to do this exercise with you I
guess probably fight brother being
played and then and then he zooms up and
they say they're sitting on a chair so
if you're sure he's shot with them
sitting in a chair and I haven't thrown
the last what happened
it's a mr. show from like that in corner
ago where you see this
at each other let me say so you do the
classic thing where you have an over
above shot for the student and a you
know from the from the bottom for the
for the teacher okay and they're sitting
in the chairs okay yeah I mean that's
enough I mean it sounds like you guys
went further than that but okay go ahead
and share it be curious to see
Wow yes sir so then thank you so you
just push it you hope I guess you want
some a little bit of comic oh that's for
soup on the side but because it does but
there's this little line okay okay cool
I like where that's going that sounds
cool did you guys have any just thoughts
or feelings about the process like just
give you a sense of like what it's
really like to do this stuff and like
have to run these scenarios through your
brain and visualize them fix your
student teacher
like that's just we have a dream of the
student for the teachers
picture student right right so you're
thinking about directorial sort of
things like how you're gonna how that
voiceover is going to change as a result
of these visual decisions you're making
yeah that's cool you guys it sounded
like there was less of a hum going on
over here did you got what do you have
for that third paragraph
basically you have the kid that's
standing there from
the last part you know it
this went away yeah yeah and the teacher
walks up with two holy chants okay cool
it sit down there's a poof of smoke and
that's my transitions to the live action
oh okay I like that
that's a cool idea and the teacher grows
also yes she's massive oh the teacher
grows in light this is how are you gonna
grow the teacher oh oh that's funny so
like maybe you stop stop action where
you take a frame and and then you put
one more pillow in or take another frame
and you you know you get like maybe and
then you do between frames and you've
got like maybe 30 or 60 frames of of
this student of this teacher getting
bigger and bigger that could be really
funny good idea
any thoughts about the process
how to make it
visually engaging I guess ya have enough
interesting shots but not too much yeah
true it's like that fine line right you
don't want to overdo it you want to you
it really really boils down to this kind
of empathy for the viewer right for
their ability to understand things and
and free maintaining this balance
between your desire to have them engaged
and their - and their need to be to
understand and kind of threading that
that that line
and you have so many shots that are just
changing too quickly it can be a very
sort of non gaining experience for the
viewer and I wrote you guys about kind
of put in the videos that we made where
that happened it would just about the
two rapid you know so we slowed it down
okay that yeah that's that's a really
good point to last really small things
that we didn't get to talk about
after-effects but it's essentially a
piece of software that lets you layer
video and artwork on top of each other
in time and you know I'm sure Elizabeth
will talk a little bit about it but if
you want to email me and you have a
specific thing you want to animate and
you want some advice about how to do it
feel free you can come by the studio and
say hey I've got this problem how would
I animate this we can give you some tips
about how you would go about doing it
and all the mats are outfitted with
after effects
the entire Adobe Creative Suite and you
guys have access to it
is that after-effects pitiful for my
Cintiq
I'm asking about maybe getting a license
for this class
just sign up on Adobe and get a month
free trial of all the Adobe Creative
Suite things so you can just sign up
with any email and download the program
to me and then the last thing I wanted
to do is just show you the video that we
actually ended up producing for this
script so
here we go mass is a measure of an
object's ability to resist being
accelerated by a force that means the
more massive an object is the harder it
is to make it move if it's at rest or
stop it if it's moving the Nifty thing
about mass is that it doesn't
necessarily have to do with size think
of a big pile of rocks and a big pile of
feathers both piles are the same size or
volume but it would take a lot more
effort or force to move the pile of
rocks then it would to move the pile of
feathers
the reason rocks have more mass than
feathers because they're more dense to
show how it's harder to accelerate
something with more mass picture a
student and a teacher each sitting at
rest in a rolling chair facing each
other let's also say the teacher is more
massive than the student when they both
push off each other they go rolling
backwards
notice how the student goes back much
farther and faster than the teacher the
teacher accelerates less since she is
the more massive of the two objects and
it takes more force to accelerate her
than it does the student all this has to
do with Newton's second law of motion F
equals MA it says for a set acceleration
an object with more mass requires more
force to get it moving at that set
acceleration as mass increases the force
required to accelerate or decelerate
that mass increases as well now don't
you feel massively smarter
all right
so that's what we ended up doing so you
know you can see how the timing allowed
us to sort of cheat a few lines like the
density line we just sort of let let it
play through you know we so you know
there's some moments here where you're
allowing the viewer to kind of take in
what's going on there's not constant
action going on you'll notice but the
action is that keep key moments you know
where we need to you know keep thinking
it's this is so abstract but again there
are no right there were no right answers
but there are some there are if you do
it long enough you'll sort of start to
get get a sense of what decisions to
make yeah question
I would say you know John you can help
me remember all this but you know the
script was maybe a couple of days you
know revisions and so forth and then we
probably probably sat down for at least
four to six hours you know almost a
whole day storyboarding it every scene
is the comp is a complex thing you know
and we were not we're not physicists so
you know we had to understand this stuff
we had to do some background research
about a day storyboarding and then a
total of three people doing the
animation and illustration and that took
maybe three weeks so I'd say about a
month to do the whole thing yeah
sure I can do that that's okay we can we
can hang out so thanks guys thanks I
mean Josh gave you guys all his info so
for today's assignment you guys will be
storyboarding one scene from your script
which is why it should it'll be a good
idea to have some semblance of a script
together I know that you're still
revising all that stuff too which is why
we're only having a storyboard one scene
and then tomorrow Chris will help you
shoot that scene so as far as the
storyboard growth you can use these
sheets you can use PowerPoint you can
use note cards but just upload upload
them as images onto tumblr and then all
the assignment details are on the
syllabus I wanted to mention this was
something that I was gonna show you guys
during the editing portion but you can
actually storyboard in post-production
after you shot things so this was an
episode on snot that I had filmed with
George and basically after we got all of
the raw footage from the first takes
these are sort of like stills from each
major scene of the video there is a
portion where I did a demo of this like
fake snot that I made but I had filmed
it in Katharina rebec's lab and the Sun
had set and my delivery was terrible I
was super tired that night so there were
a couple things that jumped out to us
after we watched everything one being
that I'm lit very dramatically and I
wanted to have more of a casual feel to
my parts and I felt like we should only
dramatically like Katharina Ribbeck the
other was that I thought well how bad
was that decision really like is it
really worth shooting again so we shot
it again because we had the time and
then it was a matter of deciding which
set of footage to
so what we're doing right now is we just
put together a cut of the video using
both clips but another thing that you
can do is storyboard the stills from the
footage that you take day of so here I
can see how that scene looks in the
context of everything else we shot so I
see that like I'm wearing a lot of blue
the the whole video looks fairly blue I
look a lot more like Katerina rebec in
this set of footage than I do the rest
of me right like the way I'm lit and all
the other scenes is really different
from this so that's what the reshot
footage looks like one the snot demo
went a lot better the second time we did
it my delivery was also a lot better but
I'm also lit a lot more flat I actually
think that the the footage that we had
before it looks a lot better like the
lighting is a lot more flattering but
it's a lot more formal and traditional
and it's hard to know how much that
jumps out in the context of the rest of
your video until you line up all these
stills any sort of storyboard this way
so we haven't actually finished this
video I'm in the process right now like
this is exactly where I am with this
video but I thought I would show it to
you today since we've been talking about
storyboarding to show how you can do it
not just in pre-production but also
after you've shot material so we have
about 20 minutes left in class I thought
that it would be good to give you guys a
chance to get started on storyboarding
your scene while we're around so if you
guys have questions I'll be here until
the end of class and a little bit later
you can ask Josh as long as he's around
but does anyone have any questions right
now
about what they need to do tonight about
storyboarding writing yeah we can also
talk about scripts right now too because
take advantage of Josh's background in
writing as well like three to four
minutes five is the absolute max
well I think I've seen those sort of
locations almost and so let me go back
to
sorry my lap bye Jamie a scene kind of
encompasses a general statement so that
the way I broke up the storyboard was I
basically just did stills of each scene
you can kind of consider the whole top
row as like a general scene one which is
how I originally scripted it it was just
sort of like the visual introduction to
the video but breaking it up into scenes
is nice because then you'll notice like
if one scene has a lot of text and then
you have a scene right afterwards that's
very short and you just have a series of
like really quick scenes maybe you can
think about restructuring or spreading
out the material a little bit more
because like I said what you don't want
is either really long shots or really
long scenes where you're not really
changing that much or if you're doing
too many really quick changes but I
don't know I don't have a good
definition for like what a scene
technically is
a unit of information yeah you know when
I think about writing I think about
paragraphs you know like this is this is
a kind of a discrete unit you know
that's imparting us a certain part of
the narrative yeah and I think the way
I'd scripted it though those four shots
are all different locations but I listed
at a scene one and like where you see
professor ryebeck and then I'm right
there in front of her I also chunk that
together as one scene but then when we
were editing and sort of taking note of
all the clips we denoted one is like
scene five and then the one after has
seen five a but in general like it's the
same sort of idea where in her lab in
that portion does anyone have any other
questions and so in this particular one
I wanted to highlight the research that
was going on here and I also wanted to
get her involved because I knew her and
I really liked and it was sort of like a
quirky breaking down the fourth wall
moment so what happens in the scene is I
set it up in the previous scene as
saying like it's not as more than just
this and then it jumps to her and she
finishes my sentence and she goes it's
actually X Y Z and then it cuts to a
wider shot reviewing that I'm in front
of her interviewing and you see the
camera interviewing her and I'm like and
then I go she would know and then her
name sort of pops up partially because
we wanted to have her in the video but
we didn't want it to be really formal
like because that shot is like a very
traditional formal interview so we
wanted to make it quirky and we also
wanted to sort of like in formalize it
so that's why we broke out of that and I
I did the whole like she would know and
then we could make that setup a little
more fun
don't you think about like the authority
of the host right because you can say
things that are easily verifiable right
but then if you're gonna say something
about snot that like most people don't
know right then like you know on whose
authority do you say this you have watch
like an Alton Brown thing there's like
alright that's wrong in like piggy are
talking about other things that I want
to know and now I don't know what you're
lying yeah well I mean part of it is
like that's the responsibility that you
have as the host is that the viewer has
sort of by default place their trust in
you I think with us we're not gonna have
as much of a problem to prove because
everyone knows that all the hosts are
students at MIT and in our YouTube
descriptions we say that all the scripts
were fact-checked by postdoc researchers
for this I mean that was one of the
reasons why we used her is because I
could explain her research or I could
just have her say it which I thought was
like a cooler window into the world here
which which is what I was talking about
on the first day like how do you create
the window into the world that people
don't have access to I also studied
bioengineering for my undergrad so with
all the material for the script came
from the class that I took from
Professor Rubik but I think you don't
take the time in your video to to
introduce yourself necessarily and maybe
you should like that's always something
we've considered is is that something
that we need to introduce into science
out loud
the host saying at the beginning like
I'm Jack and I you know work at a my T's
D lab and that's sort of what we did
with Lindsay's episode just a tiny bit
but there are ways of establishing
Authority where you don't have to
vocally do it so in Lindsay's episode we
filmed MIT SD lab and instead of saying
like we're at MIT SD lab we just spent a
few seconds doing shots of the sign that
said D lab basically if you guys want to
see it making sure you later
but I don't have a good answer for that
because I think that even if you're
Stephen Hawking people can question your
authority to say the things you're
saying and the point of the video isn't
necessarily to establish that at least
the point of these videos your material
should be accurate though yeah and so
George made me wear the goggles
partially because I think he was trying
to torture me but there there are like
some environmental health safety
standards and since we were technically
in a lab even though I wasn't work with
any working with anything biohazard
related the lab itself required goggles
so that's why I wore gloves and a lab
coat and goggles if you guys plan on
filming in any sort of environment or
that might be an issue we'll talk about
it more during producing but just keep
that in mind too we took shots of me
with and without the COG oles
just in case
any other questions
okay so I'll let you guys work and we'll
just sort of circulate through and see
if you need any help but again I just
wanted to give you some time to make the
most of the resources here